[Music]
well a lot of people push the rush of
collusion hoax but few pushed it harder
or spent more time pushing it then
former acting FBI director Andrew wood
came thanks in part to his efforts Roger
stone George papadopolis and many others
had their lives destroyed some of them
were accused of making false statements
to federal agents Roger stone faces life
in prison in a trial that starts in
November for that crime but according to
an Inspector General report
he's even as he was leading the effort
to destroy the lives of others for lying
Andy McCabe was himself lying we could
get the same treatment that his victims
are getting federal prosecutors are
weighing that question right now and how
about Jim Comey there's another
Inspector General's report about him
that also found possible criminal
behavior a lot going on tom Fitton as
the president of Judicial Watch as you
know he joins us now to sort it all out
Tom thanks for coming on first to the
Andy McCabe question will mccabe face
the consequences that so many others
have faced for this I don't know you you
raised these other folks that were
targeted general Flynn was ambushed well
thank you thanks to general thanks to
Andrew McCabe's conduct and he was
referred for criminal vestigation in
April of last year
so he's already gotten special treatment
in the sense that the Justice Department
has been agonizing over whether to
follow the leads of the IG report that
this guy lied three or four times to
investigators and we just received
documents both under oath and not under
oath so if you're talking the FBI and
you lie to him even if you're not under
oath it's a crime so what would happen
to you or me or your average fox news
viewer for doing that same thing would
we be getting the same benefit of the
doubt that mccabe appears to be in
general Flynn was prosecuted within
months Andrew McCabe they haven't
decided whether the prosecute him
because according to the New York Times
they're worried that they might get a
democratic jury here in the District of
Columbia and they won't get the
prosecution I tell you what the Justice
Department is need to needs to speed up
justice not in an improper way but
justice delayed here suggests that there
is a double standard
that if you're associated with Trump
world you get targeted if you're if
you're anti Trump you get protected
that's right we're just on the Left more
generally I mean Lois Lerner walks free
no not even even now what do we know
about the Comey report well the reports
are you know he admitted to leaking
documents FBI files he had on President
Trump to get the special counsel
appointed and the IG reportedly has
found that that was wrong
polluted classified information and he
also lacked candor and talking about it
with investigators now supposedly
Justice Department has rejected the
referral for a prosecution has declined
to pursue it I don't know if that's true
or not but I tell you what if both
Andrew McCabe and James Comey get away
with lying and leaking I tell you this
is it
it is confirmation that the deep state
rules so if you're Roger stone and
you're 67 years old and facing life in
prison because you've been accused of
lying to investigators not about
anything of substance but just be you
lied they claim right how can you look
over at these guys who lied in the
course of actually wrecking the country
and watch them get away and think this
is justice and how does that work it
doesn't work and if I were the president
I would be pardoning people like stone
in a heartbeat Flynn the rest of them
caught up in Mulder's web and you know
we're just talking about relatively
minor crimes compared to the seditious
coup that took place and the illegal
spying on President Trump I understand
there's a US attorney and kinetic during
that's Connecticut and Durham that's
looking at this but I haven't seen any
indications of a significant criminal
inquiry into the most significant
corruption scandal in American history
the spying on President Trump that was
illegal I mean is the IG going to come
out on the FISA Gate report on the FISA
Gate warrants say that there was
something improper there and nothing's
going to be done again I tell you it
doesn't augur well and this is this is a
sign that the Justice Department
has been terribly corrupted and it
hasn't been fixed yet by the Attorney
General it's making a lot of us very
cynical unfortunately not fitting great
see you thanks